[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off-the-record or we talk about
whatever we want and we have to hear
back how do you favorite yes yeah hey
that's my ball I know one cares about
Steve because about the sponsor thank
you to our sponsor native deodorant
native create simple safe effective
products that people use in the bathroom
everyday native Beulah is formulated
without aluminum parabens and talc hmm
and use ingredients found in nature such
as coconut oil shea butter and tapioca
starch and native is never ever tested
on animals that's the best part about it
making the switch to aluminum free
deodorant does not mean having to
sacrifice on product performance native
has over nine thousand five star reviews
it comes in a variety of scents for men
and women such as coconut vanilla
lavender and rose and cucumber and mint
they also have an unscented formula and
a baking soda free formula for those
with sensitivities for 20% off your
first purchase visit native deodorant
calm and use promo code OTR during
checkout baby yeah and there's no rest
to try native offers free shipping as
well as returns and exchanges in the US
of A again for 20% off your first
purchase visiting your native deodorant
calm and use promo code OTR during
checkout Thank You native it smells
really good
that's cool man I like deodorant
[Laughter]
actually needs probably try to do
something like this because I got these
I get these lumps under my arm like my
lip noise gets low and usually it's like
it's just a little ball and then like
recently it got really swollen it was
like very tinder like put my arm down
and then it actually bursts and I was
like I don't know what the hell inside I
just had that too yeah like a week ago
yeah I took pictures of it like it was
like a cyst almost so like it was pus
coming out so like that I
outside yeah it bursts on the outside so
it's like hey we broke the skin and I
was like sorry I did some research and
it was like because I'm probably using
like it could be from aluminum and the
the odor and enology
do you have do you get ingrown hairs I
do but like not here like usually like
on this reason and like sometimes in the
back and they're not constant NASA trip
man a week ago I had a swollen s lymph
node two on my armpit and I let I looked
it up and in always like it could be
cancer yeah always sure well Bambi is
sponsored by Claro
I know my cancer is a person they're
like yeah this is all research places
yeah you keep getting money like this it
always comes back to Kansas I got a
cough it must be cancer you know pretty
sure I got chlamydia you go for another
like you comedians cause my can see like
[ __ ] man I cannot get away from this
thing [ __ ] you Big C untreated chlamydia
can't turn into cancer though that's no
[ __ ]
really yeah it's really fun to to come
back yeah I didn't know that everything
that's crazy but yeah I had that [ __ ] -
and I was like looking it up like what
the [ __ ] do I have cancer or whatever
but it's like burst - no that was the
first time but but usually they come
swell and then they go down yeah like in
a couple of days but this is the first
time I get careful I don't know because
I was active and you know I've been
working out more and I just kept the
friction on it in the basement and she
was painful growth right after you get
sick or right when you're about to get
sick and your body's fighting off a
virus or bacteria it could flush out all
of that stuff in that limb through there
so everything that puff dough is all
this stuff they I don't know about the
popping on that might just be friction
comitia cares at this table right there
if that's how it worked [ __ ] I'll take
it any day any time now yeah have you
been I've been good man I've been saving
this this like a hearty hearty [ __ ] you
to bar cuz I've never got a good bite to
the gym I see you a posting pictures of
the gym all the gyms finally opens I'm
drowning and all it is here I've been
working out a 24 hour fitness sharing
agreement on your workout Oh
I've been proud of myself for this whole
year lose the 38 pounds and now you
didn't work out you were you lost 30
congratula [ __ ] you want man nah man
this is all this is all fluff for you
man remember your Co competition yeah I
seen all the way doorway been losing
that no one has been posting a [ __ ]
don't mind his loss to turn away I'm
very proud of social media while he says
he wants an invite like let's go next -
yeah I mean workout video together cool
I don't know come work out but like the
video I don't know if I'm ready for that
okay
you know I've confident you have to be
to walking somewhere in your underwear
just to under word not boxes either way
either way I'm not there lay on that on
that end of the spectrum up closer more
to the Scimitar he did that when he was
fat - oh really it's not up yeah he's
not bad I got on purpose one time Green
I was just want to get as strong as I
can so just pounding food oh man are you
doing like keto you just pounded any
type of food McDonald's oh really
you give a [ __ ] about your life no I had
to be before the baby because I know
like if he was doing to say that with
the baby like we got a baby now you
can't be doing the type of crazy [ __ ]
that'd be less like 50 pounds in like
three months
really it was time yes doping you were
pregnant yeah were you eating going
right to sleep - like old fat [ __ ] like
that no but every meal is a shoot
my shoes yeah I'll try tied one I need
to take a break before you lose like I
have to hold my breath to tie my shoe
like when you're fat you have to figure
out like the best way to tie your shoe
it's not like bidding over like this
you got the squat squat down because he
bit over you your stomach you can't
breathe man I know I know all the fat
guy tricks putting on socks stand up cuz
I trying to bend down to die bro I can't
bend over do it cuz I can't breathe I
don't either cuz I've been husky all my
drink some [ __ ] six-year-olds I know
man
I understand against the wall it's like
I keep my balance they just throw that
laid-back we little treats man I know
how to make this [ __ ] work
I'm bout there like though that's cute
as [ __ ] when I'm no trying to lose
weight so I could just worship bizarre
Tim says he's a large and Zara who's
like five three yeah right that's what
he said is elderly that's really like
the feds are did youuuu words are I have
one I had one vest from Zara but I'm
aware it was a Jean vest yeah I double
XL it was like a large or extra-large I
was like big okay yeah but I was I was
actually ten pounds lighter when I was
wearing it too really yeah oh did you
say it made you feel buff yeah was like
a tank top on I'm a tank top with
buttons you know big as hell in the
Whedon's oh yeah and no reason like the
average height for females or is like
between 5 9 5 11 yeah doctor Scandinavia
my people
you ever been to Amsterdam oh yeah I
just went a couple was like when you get
off the the trainer of the plane and you
just see the mannequins at like bit of
Foot Locker
you're like why the [ __ ] does everyone
look like a linebacker that's just big
the average height is like 6 2 or
something that's crazy
yeah yeah Scandinavia where the hell
big elbow height madness follow up with
that I just wish that once again sure
and I keep thinking this is like the
Rose rose Purina Rose Parade small lady
on my daughter today when I was getting
out there that are you wearing your
Roseboro
is it my homeboys clothing line I like
desert you know did you work on three
Rose Parade mom my family does I don't
go I'm not a big girl per a guy anxiety
kicks in horn why are the people there
yeah like I got it I like I've never
like been like that before I've always
be able to do crowd smells more like as
of late like big crowds freak me out I
was at the party do you stand up yes I
leave I get to get off the stage I go
right back to the gray room and I drink
but like I don't really sit the crowd
like that's all never crowd surfing oh
[ __ ] like that I don't go to concerts
unless I'm alike I have a section like I
don't do the whole standing in the
crowds I think it's like concerts with
seats now yeah yeah especially real
concert they've like you like doors open
at 8:00 and the first one [ __ ]
onstage like 11:30 black I was standing
this whole goddamn town and a drunk man
I need to sit down yeah okay
I hate at this point my old man you
sound like an old man I like you though
I worked hard to get it I'm at the age
now I don't feel bad when people get in
the car and I Z brothers are playing why
don't you listen to this [ __ ] cuz I'm
old okay you know your friends gonna
call you oh let me put on the baby real
quick yeah no give wrong no the baby's
new guys are I don't I know the baby I
like the baby because there's a rapper
that recently passed away and yeah yeah
they're all sad about it and then I was
like I don't even know who this guy is I
think my daughter knew some my songs but
I wasn't for me I found what like and I
ride with him like I like the baby right
he gets me high you don't think I look
dances he makes me want to commit armed
robbery
I'm gonna do it
as I can't go to jail because I'm big
but I would think what did I what did
they want it for hip points for the [ __ ]
home bears D yeah bear I always felt
like bear was the one that's over the
other guy yeah da did make me a little
spoon - oh yeah a bigger bear could come
yeah okay do it man I gotta lose these
childbearing hips before I ever think
about going to Jess I'm gonna always be
on the right side of got some big thighs
a lot of heat coming up designed to
carry what I'm saying get to Hardy when
they see it I'll walk in and all I got
look amazing you all right so I'm
walk-in in the horns and Jamie let a
great bottle right there don't call me
red huh a grown man just call the red
balls like nah don't do that that's a
term for a light-skinned black people
let's get chicks oh I can't [ __ ] yeah
you too a big south well so it's red
ball red ball cuz like like you have red
hair so they call them red red ball for
like that little ice get rid of it hey
red
hey what I read disrespectful
have you ever been in cat call while
you're teaching in jail no I was I've
seen people get caught hair caught in
jail like when I was I'm literally
teaching in class and then one of the
guys that I guess gets a lot of
attention walk by and then one of the
guys was in class he's looking at me
like oh boy
I'm telling it's up light at all and I
was like all right this is what we're
not gonna do all right we're not gonna
disrupt the class what pants are the
guys walking around with two eggs and
milk or does not know happen if you ask
him
uh-huh are you gay is he like [ __ ] no I
wouldn't ask you something
question she don't need to know every
like like you got this is it like that
god I wouldn't want to know what the
purpose of life is even like just for my
amusement my heart would crumble right
so searching hang go ask questions to
that I don't want to know the answer I'm
not prepared to know that Dalila have
dudes come in there and talk to people
there's never no females ever come in no
like they give you a long list of rules
and regulations do's and don'ts and that
type of stuff like certain things like
if they complimented my shoes the way
you did I would have to tell one of the
COS and they would probably put them in
the brig for that or they would put them
in a solitary wolf wait because they're
like a mark on your shoe someone uh.well
solitaire is all by yourself I don't
know they bring something else I don't
know I just said I heard it all somebody
else saying nothing like a compliment
can lead to a favor so I say hey man
he's sharp today fancy but you know
where you get them from ok cool they try
to build out the relationship and they
eventually they be like me and like I do
this for you don't worry about it I'm
like okay cool reset and then they'll
come back a week later hey remember when
I did that for you I need you to do
something for me
now you caught up in a quid pro quo and
now you gotta suck gotta get a sandwich
from the outside into something else
no I noticed once she got caught up with
some [ __ ] and the dude had him dude had
her taking her taking his daughter to go
shopping and [ __ ] like that like it was
a whole like scandal like it was in the
nose and all that I was it the
[ __ ] are smart dealer they are
professionals a conniving and cunning
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's like real
like have you spent all your money put
your money on the green dot gave it to
the air I remember when I first start
working at this one chick had two to two
guys older one was like older brother do
was finger banging it and like in the
classroom like she just didn't give a
[ __ ] this is sweet the teacher the
teacher she was engaged
she had a master's from UCLA like
all of the shoes she risked it all these
[ __ ] whose you facing 10 years to
inland they had a ma orgy in there yes
and how did you willingly
I didn't wanna do I just hurt her like
this one of the stories that they told
me before like right when I started oz
is like dang God like what could you say
to her they were like yeah risk it all
for me my god [ __ ] going for myself
you're right right yeah yeah you got a
master's that means you put in at least
six years for this one focus and this is
what you want to do for rest of your
life you just book it off for a quick
finger bag I know but that's a lot of
dick though might be big fingers yeah
yeah big fingers she was like my husband
doesn't have to my god my buddy my buddy
worked at a the court system the jail
system and he was saying like it was
this hot ass girl that kept coming by an
app off like shoe try to build rapport
with the cops cuz she was she's actually
her dad is like Mexican Mafia or
something so he she would come and visit
and then she would always try to talk to
some of the cops and be like oh you can
I have these extra tacos you guys want
some yeah and then he'll be like nah
that's cool
but he's like damn she was so [ __ ]
fine they're always in a small dress and
[ __ ] and then one cop would take them
eat them and she'll keep bringing them
back and be like hey I got some extra
ones for my dad can you give these to
him and you'll be like yeah sure yo
through the dad and then soon enough
that cop got caught because she would
hide drugs in there
yeah I thought that's why I like don't
do it man
that's why they do is just insane no
value said is a women's prison or jail
in Lynwood and I only had to go there
like a couple of times actually I went
to Lynwood sedan that's one that's women
prison downtown I taught there like
three times and like I always work alone
I always dress a certain way and you
know look well-kept and soon as I walk
there they're like damn I'm trying to
let he'll get me pregnant I was like I'm
going to leave I'm not doing it he
turned around like cuz I might do it
yeah
I'm only a man they just walking around
like and they will do stuff like soon as
I'm walking the court and they like they
got like three like there's a section
right there a section right here a
section right there and like because
it's like a like group sleeping until
that guy so some of that walking one of
them like literally walk into the glass
and put a TV on the glass I was like no
no this is the case waiting to happen
I don't know parts of this at all so I
don't know I don't know maybe it's a
certain type of meal or because they
after that they told me like yeah he's
probably shouldn't wear cologne in here
just like whether you it makes him too
horny yeah it was yeah it was tiger
blood 50% of the time and watch all the
time so I was like yeah yeah tiger blow
is not a real thing but I'm speaking I'm
being catcalled by a guy I almost got
recruited by a gay pimp oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah I was at the toy district in
downtown LA cuz I had the finest where
we would sell like airsoft guns and [ __ ]
like that so have my sunglasses on it
was hot ass [ __ ] day I'm carrying
this [ __ ] right and his guy comes up and
he's like man I know a lot of fine man
that would love a Latino boy like you I
took off my glasses I'm Mexican and I
walk those guys oh so short man I don't
know what to do that's pretty scary
what do you like he called you out a
little bit like oh [ __ ] he saw something
in you that you haven't found in
yourself yet like I'm that really yeah
or did your butthole tighten man I was
scared but I always like at the same
time I'm like I'm not a [ __ ] I got to
say something about this and it's just a
reaction and instead of saying [ __ ] no
or whatever I
I'm not Mexican I just what have you
challenged you he goes are you a [ __ ]
oh I know [ __ ] give me that dick that
kind of contradicts itself but I know
right yeah man it was one of those like
reactions though so I can see why like
women are like what the [ __ ] don't care
cuz they don't even know what to do
sometimes yeah in Mexico we have our
rebuttals so I guess they go you
remember it's like it's like a rap
battle it is yeah so you already have
your responses to the typical cat calls
that they will say like for example one
of them it's like like Oh chick eat eat
that right and then like meaning like
all the cute little girl but like you
know more like sexual way that they see
it and then the rebuttal to that is like
like Venus been there for like you have
it really small it's too small
I would swallow you whole yeah do they
do they have rebuttals to your rebuttal
[ __ ] like with the words like the
word Smiths in Spanish and I'm not
always like how do you even come up with
that [ __ ] they write it down - well if
she says this dick is small oh yeah well
so are you perfect fit girl you know
like that's all they do all shitty
they're like they just had their
headphones on and they're just like
nothing right now I think you're small
but so is your [ __ ] no man just [ __ ]
writing rebuttals all day and if you
said they can't call me say this I must
say this that make sense yeah first off
I got hit on to LA it was weird I had
reason just moved out here and I was at
the gas station about the pace there's
two people in front of me and a guy
walks in behind me
the gas station was right on Melrose in
Fairfax a gas station like that right so
I'm standing there the guy walks in he's
like mmm and I heard the UH
but I was like nope I yeah yeah so I
would ignore it - no cap no gag one
person leaves now it's just me then one
person in front of me is I listen I
don't mean to bother you nothing you
talking me I guess I just want to let
you know you an attractive man right
right I was like hey man listen no
disrespect I really no that ain't really
my thing I don't I don't swing it like
that he's all sweetheart I'm not trying
to [ __ ] you okay I'll just let you know
that you're handsome I was like cool I
appreciate it nighttime background he's
like cuz if I wanted to [ __ ] you you'd
be [ __ ] that was just like and I was
just like yo that's so wild so I'll pay
for my gas I go outside I was pumping my
gas [ __ ] really just trying to [ __ ]
nobody on that pump gas but then I was
like but he really tried to [ __ ] what he
did to you Popat what he did to us you
ain't even that fine anyway [ __ ] like
I've seen thicker I was like
[Music]